aleshin aleshin e aí galera que assistiu
canal do banco você e eu sei que vocês
me pedem para fazer logo esbarrou nele
logo entendeu que a gente é ter um saco
para fazer dele só já o negócio deixou
de assistir mais o que fazer pelo corpo
não cancelada também rock é meu sol raiá
com muita gente perto a fazer o que eu
vou fazer eu vou fazer um governo mês
netão filmar uma viagem de um show já
fez uma vez que foi um show em natal que
eu vi e agora estão indo para são paulo
em esse final de semana temos quatro
show em são paulo quatro chun an é e sai
de onde eu moro que é sobral no ceará
está em papel e resina piauí também na
vaga do braia aí lá eu pego um vôo mais
bonito seria mais para pegar vôo em
fortaleza seria mandar só quando o pai
não quiser a água então estão aí para
teresina agora 370 quilômetros de
estrada e também o irmão fazendo vários
contos ohtake bob 2 nec é foi visitá lá
em casa tem que me explicar também outro
amigo comediante que só tem que só entra
como é do meu carro
papai voltar e deixa ele não vai querer
saltar uma dia 15 em japão da certinha
agora estamos passando pela cidade de
tianguá
no peito o do meu deus
tem ser humano num
nervoso
ae
love to ontem chico
a rainha do meu dinheiro vai agora fazer
uma peripécia eu fui conseguir aqui do
lado de fora
só que o abrigou vida a 100 por hora foi
com os vidros do carro causam pai ou
aqui no carro tony chega lá galera acha
que é que é detalhe a voz pode
customizar ficar desse jeito eu pensei
ficar aquela era a gente está aqui no
terra piauí e é se sentir se aproximando
de piripiri escravo cortando nordeste
leste e oeste o sol sudeste sorocaba não
testa mec mas galera
agora vamos sentar ao mec
vicente chega lá pelo menos pelo mesmo é
no medo às 6 horas é por que dirige à
noite é muito e hoje eu pego ou às duas
da manhã então vou chegar não vai
abandonar uma curtida matar salário o
amigo e faz tempo que não vejo que haja
muito calminho e ela teresina são tabu
na óptica da carreta é que é o
transporte
ele é um filme que vem lá ela é o mesmo
até rebateu as coisas que ela estamos
aqui em cocal de telha para tomar o bom
e velho caldo tal daqui a tia tinha um
equipamento daquela da saúde e isso
causa é bom não é
é bom o carro não é ruim é bom
super show
ora também aí atrás e eu tenho o meu eu
dei comigo a pasta é doido é desse cara
é doida e provendo coca com o sopa e dá
um banho tempere de morte e uma
paradinha equipo abençoa o papai é uma
bênção do pai de kim tae young
sempre é bom andar a paradinha para o
papai eu tenho que colocar também aí o
homem é esta
é acabou de chegar aqui em teresina
acabou não é quem já faz um tempo que a
gente chegou em teresina chegar na cara
do brasil é que demora porque a gente
chegou nos horários de pico no horário
de pico às 6 horas chegou todos os
cargos meio da rua e aí está a 16 e 41
agora da entrada da cidade até chegar
perto da casa do brasil só 40 minutos
vai atacar o iraque em direção à casa do
braga viaja muito boa graças a deus não
aconteceu nada nem animal na pista nem o
acidente não viu batido no domingo nada
só aconteceu uma coisa nessa viagem
zoeira vamos embora já era a cara do
brasil já que chegamos aqui no culpado
de carga com tanta saudade que eu tá
chegando só a culpa é aí que o bom é que
tá gente é uma próxima à cidade mas
também não rolar amigo estava atrás
saudades de você
gente o filme dias ai ta o dia de hoje
até o que é pena responder toda hora
sobre esse filme gente faltam oito cenas
para gravar só que no coxa é tempo no um
vídeo meus vídeos são 50 mil acessos no
mar quando chega eu peço para o preço
vai falar 190 mata acabou o filme
terminou brasil o filme é por aí
gente pelo amor de deus não tem muito
mais sobre esse filme não por favor
dessa galera a gente acabou de chegar
vou me ajeitar a idéia já volto a falar
com você
galera agora estamos partilha clicar
dubai já teve um momento de descontração
e conversar horas exatamente o e meia da
manhã e duas horas em itaí foi o porto
agora pega o avião para são paulo e do
meu povo não vou falar com o padre
eu já tenho viu
valeu agora vou para o povo o primeiro
curso não foi campeã no túmulo do sul
chega no canto deixando todo mundo
vou dormir lá poderia tema favorável
certa cartão de embarque sem precisar de
ajuda para guardar a bagagem é só avisar
caso você prefira não assentar a saída
de emergência podemos tratar ela chegou
no são paulo soul sucka entre deste
tamanho porque como sempre por bonito aí
persona de 130 manhã trouxa a encontrou
na globo
ganhava o hotel descansar e amanhã o
barueri futebol
inuk da desgraça é esse de outubro
totalmente preparada culpa participou
nos vocais uma tática é a parte de baixo
estão a praia em são paulo como final
tempo james pena país que tornou
o meu deus entrar na bahia e também
condições de fazer a piada hora dessas
não é que a van que vai pegar a gente e
agora o hotel na vila foi profunda o que
eu sou da turma da bacalhôa agora
finalmente no hotel possa deus é
exatamente 7 27 da manhã eu tô indo
dormir agora que há pouco a copa falar
com vocês quando é obrigado jaló o dia
todo meus pano de agosto exatamente uma
e dez na tarde o índice é uma hora da
tarde está dando onde na hora que acorda
pra mim é bom dia tá levantar como o
ambiente é para conversar com foco em um
bairro de boston a galera show jack
barueri são paulo
a gente quer que vistam ainda pomar meu
teu c eu toco e eu estou com muita
vontade de fazer logo seja porque o
lugar que tinha muita vontade de ver o
pessoal e no mar e eu vou estar
sinalizada de barueri são gostosas amiga
galera já estamos aqui no teatro fim da
passagem de som é conferida aqui teatro
bonito da scar lindo demais ordem de
mailing mais milhões só que não foi
votada
aí tem que passar o microfone né para o
xingu pa deu show sabonetinho lugar
muito legal não sei o que é e hoje vai
ser muito bom que acabou de me dizer que
já está esgotado os ingressos para a
gente são paulo é o passo como se fosse
a segunda fase e deu porque o pessoal
aqui tem muitos humorista entendeu então
quando vem o dia outro lugar você tem
que acreditar que a pressão é boa então
tem que mostrar para as pessoas que eu
sou bom gente e seis cada um à parte de
chão que eu subo ele joga na platéia que
todos possam ficar brincando que segura
uma baleia pula simon
saviola obrigado em português um olho
não
não ter vendido o chinelo pai deixou
muito obrigado deus obrigado eu tenho
falado na internet
eu eu falei sim acho você falasse bem eu
falei se ganhar quem tiver que jogar vai
computar difícil a vida da gente que até
paga o só para falar bem e ainda quer
mais
a gente vai ver como é que é o carinho e
vou convidar o preso e ficar mais ligado
e nada brinca e diz que acabou de
eliminar chocolate viu galera já estamos
aqui no bom e velho lugar do show teatro
ajuda equivalente a 6 sujo eu penso
buraco mec a nossa mãe e tenho que falar
em liga e fala umbigo né
eu falo em vi que eu estou aqui com
roupa bem despojada olha só que legal já
que eu vou pôr a equipa não congelado em
si iceberg ea blusa aqui do fã clube de
porto velho olha que legal porto velho
também tem visto todos muito legal e eu
não vou mostrar que agora é o lugar onde
robert escreveu quando é que vai poder
tirar foto
nunca olha só que veio prestigiar o show
aqui em pessoal
o cara foi para a platéia começou a
gritar com skate
aí ele fica com ódio as coisas no
restaurante é a melhor pizza de frango
aí o cara com molho de playstation
dacar com a alexandre relvas vai dar o
efeito é bicho e inconveniência do
[ __ ] de maio boa agora imagina do
bicho ia ficar muito coisa sabe eu a 4
já o telefone tocou
aí quando atendia o telefone a mulher
desesperada meu filho te amo por favor
me emocionada interrompendo a yoki essas
coisas é o tipo de coisa que não se
interrompe casa foi o carro tá aqui ó
trata só de boca só de rock
aí é só dar mole e duro fazer
brincadeira aconteceu na hora que eu vi
a reação da breve a mulher que se
esperava ninguém com vergonha a marca de
vergonha mesmo sabendo que a gente não
faça um filho né
alfa assim é pois é aí o cara dá
realmente para a web foi importante pra
ela está em terra firme a foto com a
galera
agora é hora do show espero que todo
mundo diz que seus problemas
tava no trânsito hoje começa o trabalho
foi de 378 todo mundo esquecer um
pouquinho dos seus problemas e se
entregue só risada ea gargalhada para
fazer todo mundo feliz nessa noite neto
vamos lá é nós deus abençoe o doente
maioria
ae i
ae
o motoboy galera acabou o show foi muito
bom 8 legal todo mundo riu nota da sua
casa para ver se pode ver a foto aí no
instagram se quiser jogar aqui na tela
foto que você vê e agora vou tirar foto
com a galera e e depois vão ao hotel não
podía assim já está acordado acabei de
acordar e estão escutando do banheiro
ele que está esquentando a rotina tira
um banho simpatia aos erótico 18
e é tomar um banho comigo dandão o qual
é o dia d qual é a boa do dia onde a
gente vai para campinas e são paulo
fazer um show enquanto foi tópico
chamado top na balada e aí vamos lá
fazer esse show louco bem legal vai ter
um evento local ele passou a se eu vou
lá curtir e é isso aí ó tomar um banho
no rótulo olha só eu e bonito e agora
sim bem bonito de banho tomado
cheirosinho com a mesma jaqueta porque
só tenho é essa hoje prossegue agora
pinel sozinho a dito que eu darei
extintores se abre ao solicitado ao que
é viciado meu deus meu oitavo vermelho
eu sou eu desde o café tamar pneus
urucará teve uma queda valeu joelho nem
soro meu deus eu estava cagando acabou o
papel aí eu vou tomar amanhã eu também
vou limpar um cubo não sou mais eu vou
te dar a bunda e filme é o choro então
galera vamos obedecer e vamos lá ela
estamos agora em direção à campinas vai
ter um show lá hoje é hoje 7 horas aqui
um show que a gente tá aí pra lá
garantiu
uma passadinha aqui josé hardcore
emerson também testou
israel
acho
ae
túlio fingiu dormir bem
o conselho não sei nem se descuidam da
mentira
eu
acabou de sair que acabam de sair do
evento lado do cauê mil x curti muito
bacana agora finalmente meio em campinas
é fazer um bom jogo e vamos embora não
chegam aqui em campinas o teatro já
gravaram a gente vai discutir vai direto
do teatro já olha aqui e ver como é que
é inspirar muito o show bonito que só
deu um toque lindo esse teatro vai dá
gosto para no teatro bonito assim né daí
porque lindo do ic lindo para que lhe
pedira para chegar onde não é só
descansar um pouco
aqui nesse eu sei que ganhou ontem o
barueri no legal muito obrigado a
química amparo legal só agora vou dormir
um pouquinho galera tá
tinha letra mas eu vou dormir - já o
show que agora vai entrar nós vamos ver
como é que a agenda pessoal aqui de
campinas todo me para aqui mais
com 10
hoje a linha já a galera olha que vai se
apresentar aqui e logo depois da minha
peça aí estão aí o cara está fazendo
negócio do exército muito legal tive
prazer já encontrei no ninho da parada
da copa que a gente foi lá só não vai
dar pra ficar porque o outro já agora em
são paulo tem que sair voando joão faria
baixo chico rei correr mas eu estou aqui
amanhã e depois foi para curitiba e há
dois dias fica no ponto e vou correr
para não falar agora
valeu irmão boa apresentação pra você
ainda não valeu uma faixa a lei vai dar
certo
boa festa pra vocês obrigada viu
valeu galera acabou né aqui em campinas
foi muito foi do carro a droga e r 18 e
agora vai voar para são paulo para poder
fazer a admiro este hoje ainda né agora
está saindo do teatro de campinas direto
o teatro de são paulo vai fazer logo de
lá voar
não é e não é ligada ao o eu ia falar
não reclamei que ele não olhou o eu na
liga
obrigado minha gente
valeu tcheco passou a falar agora deve
pegar o nelson tudo bem não vai poder
contar com o tempo e agora partiu são
paulo outros e aí galera acabam de
chegar aqui já no teatro fernando torres
uma que já parece bem bonito lá de fora
vamos entrar fazer como é pela
dissidência quando olha batendo o deco
20 impresso ratos e bateu
estamos aqui no câmera em rondônia só qd
e vem reclamar no top
acho que é isso também sentindo aé - se
ficar amarelo
sou eu pegava o java que é o teatro que
ser punidos
galera agora é a hora depois velho show
em hebe normal só agora meia noite o
flamengo chegou em são paulo e
botavam sendo estudada quando alguém
tenho falou agora vou poder show vocês
se pode aí vocês galera acabou o show
foi muito bom a galera maravilhosa olha
quem tá é que chegue o jogo
como encara super recomendo pois é quem
mais tem que saber como eles show época
da infância época foi o quarto na foto
chama família é porque é bom a família
consegue junto ou já tinha dito mas essa
turma da hora de decidir que estava em
uma loja você merece né e pesa muito bom
tocar agogô chuva
ai ai ai galera acabam de chegar
galera acabei de chegar aqui motel local
muito limpa dormir e um negócio que você
chegará para fazer mais nada agora tomar
o remédio aqui ó dizer tomou remédio
aqui domingo que amanhã em vinhedo papo
vamos fazer o seguinte vou dormir já vou
aparecer amanhã hoje oferecido inovado
bonito lindo lindo já não garanta a
pessoa até amanhã
olha só quem está aqui mais uma vez
quando vocês vêem galera acabei de
acordar na verdade faz uns 20 minutos
aconteceu pouco você na minha cara de
tabaco e vilão dizer que a gente já tá
aí pra vinhedo acordamos já diretamente
em vinhedo a pauta que consomem na a
arrumar minhas coisas que está o povo
bagunçado e vou descer e pavão
que chique que antes aqui é ser uma tela
é é uma senhora para o medo é finalmente
chegamos aqui em vinhetas uólhem cidade
bonita cara deixa a cidade é linda e tão
apaixonado na cidade
olha é toda decorada dinha cara
olha a ima hoyas casa parece dever da
vila do chaves
finalmente já que no hotel é da
descansada porque hoje é vinheta olha
que beleza
eita eita
eita olha só uma cidade bonita o que
mais o que aconteceu aí tudo bem não sei
o que aconteceu
eita apareceu o ranço galera já estamos
agora no dirigindo ao teatro olha que
lugar legal esse corredor e e é
transforme o cara vai andando quanto
mais anos mas acende a luz assim travar
começassem a 2
e olha só eu tenho que chama uma coisa
moral cara anda e assim cuidar do uso ou
é moral e acendimento automático é aí
que tal estou eu sou superman oitão a
lagoa do oscar a picar longe
ae
eita em diante um bom como é nossa
motorista e tá beleza todo momento
é só rir a ata do g20 é que sorri pa
a batalha não sei mais de onde eu tiro
rio porque 4 e vai joão falar com ele
pra vocês eu tô cansado da área e eu
tenho uma cachorrinha solange solange eu
chegar em casa o charlotte pra vocês o
que só deve chover
i e ii
isso não é aquela que é a rapariga pinha
roubada de caxito um pacto já vai
começar de um jeito agora o fone
agora tenho um banco que isso causa pode
não voltar e ver qual é a galera hora do
show
vamos embora deus abençoe e que seja só
risadas coisas boas
ai ai ai ai ai
a galera show foi muito bom ala gil pra
[ __ ] foi bom foi adorei participar
são paulo de novo disse ivan
vou chegar lá amanhã pegar vôo pra casa
vamos embora vem com a gente é
vamos a uma das suas coisinhas e partiu
piauí o ganhei você de novo ele estava
dormindo era só um autorização
para isso
chegando em teresina já a galera então
poderá pagar o porto porque estava
cansado e queria ter dado interessante
para vocês ver e ouvir logo com o pai de
felipe melo o povo olha ele que meu pai
de quem vota nele ele veio com um
simples inteira isso é mentira é porque
é meu compadre comprou o xbox m31
comprou o jogo
acho que nem se ligou que não dá para
jogar é que tem a rios city são
sensibilizados derrota unida é
eu falei agora vou ajudar vou ajudar o
amigo para jogar o caminhão
lá pegar a parede o pega ninguém sabia
pra mim é não chegar lá e cá não me
deixes box um ano que tem sou eu vou
jogar atacando
aqui eu tenho em meu ponto é que gente
olha alegria na família
veja só comecei a falar e até até que na
quinta-feira 20 realmente ver que
realmente só pegar os jogos afirma eu
não queria mais um jogo na minha mãe
falou quem tá certo aí galera agora a
gente vai voltar pra casa são cinco
horas a gente vai dirigir um pouco de
noite é então como vocês já viram como é
que a estrada é como é que a gente viaja
no carro tudo então não vou gravar volta
aqui o carro que a gente vai dirigir de
noite é que é um pouco mais de atenção
deve ser carregado na pista
dá pra ficar conversando pra câmera fato
a gente ainda agora quando chegar em
sobral com vocês beleza e agora se não
aparecer em sobral galera finalmente
cheguei em casa
já estou aqui e olha só o que eu quero
apresentar para vocês pois ela é feita
de manhã e foi um olha gente olhe
mandar o jogo em um quilo que essa aqui
é a solanja solange é lógico por causa
do aviões do forró salas de reuniões
nessa hora a gente sabe que eu tinha meu
gato é de safadão só que ele dá volta
por aqui
eu acho que como ele ficou conhecido o
pessoal roubou ele saiu daqui de casa e
aí nunca mais apareceu dá por conta
disso decidimos mostrar somente assim
que ela chegou e tal ficar me achar que
é ainda mãe galera é isso aí eu espero
que você tenha gostado de passar esses
dias comigo tá
já vocês sabem mais ou menos como é que
é minha vida no final de semana para
saber onde tem show e como comprar
ingressos só entrar no meu site que está
aparecendo aqui na tela e galera sério e
muito obrigado ter ficado comigo até
aqui tá que é meu é pichette que o
instagram meu twitter me segue lá valeu
é nóis sobre uma vez por mês vão fazer
um deles está não vou substituir nem
ouvir esse é um vídeo a parte já uma
evidência na quinta não na terça não sei
mas muito obrigado em casa xv até aqui é
muito importante mesmo ser um vídeo de
diário vencer um vídeo é sobre o meu dia
mesmo se não vota mal é muito importante
você clica e gostei que eu falei poxa
pessoal gostou desse estilo de vídeo ou
tentar fazer pelo menos uma vez por mês
então clique gostei aí pela média de
likes se estiver muito fácil mais beleza
muito obrigado valeu é nóis ibram e
jorge henrique e vou correr na minha
casa no campo solta